[Music]
sisterhood 3 any possibility are we any
closer to one we we want it to have it I
really hope so I mean it keeps kind of
coming up and we're really trying to
make it happen so I really hope so
Alexis Bledel keeping hope alive for a
Sisterhood of the Traveling Pants
threequel
at the season 2 premiere of Hulu's The
Handmaid's Tale we come here we work we
died the scope of this show is so much
bigger than last year right I mean it
feels like an epic what was it like to
learn more about Emily I was so excited
to flashback and get to depict the story
of who she was pre Gilly ad show her
kind of in all her glory thriving you
know doing what she loves working as a
professor of cellular biology and you
know loving being a mom and the family
life that's a very full life and and how
crushing to see her ripped away from all
of that I mean I think it really you
really feel what a shame that is to take
to take things away from a woman who is
thriving
[Applause]
[Music]